عام
1930 احتاجت شركه امريكيه لمساحه اكثر
لمكاتبها لم تنتقل الى مبنى اخر اكبر
مساحه بل قامت بازاحه مبناها الاساسي من
مكانه دون ان تهمه او حتى ان تطلب من
الموظفين اخائه فكيف حدث ذلك القصه
العجيبه حدثت عندما ارادت شركه هواتف
بولايه انديانا مساحه اضافيه لتشييد مبنى
اخر المهندسون توصلوا الى حل عبقري وغريب
في نفس الوقت حيث قاموا بتدوير المبنى
الذي كان وزنه يفوق الاحد عشر الف طن
ويتكون من ثمانيه طماطم وتم تحريكه بواسطه
رافعات يدويه مدفوعه بقوه محرك بخاري
تمكنت من ازاحته بمعدل خمسه عشر بوصه في
الساعه اما الموظفون فكانوا يعملون بشكل
طبيعي داخل المبنى ولم يشهدوا قطاعا في
الغاز او الكهرباء وحتى المياه والصرف
الصحي كما كانوا يخرجون ويدخلون منه بحريه
تامه بفضل رصيفه خشبيا متحرك العمليه هذه
استغرقت شهرا ونجحت في النهايه بتدوير
المبنى بزاويه 90 درجه من موقعه الاصلي
ليتسنى للشركه تشييد المبنى الاضافي